what's the difference between a roll of  butter paper and a brand new iPad well  there's only one key difference and as  Architects that is more folio Trace with  butter paper we're limited by one simple  thing and it's simply  the length of the Roll whereas with more  folio Trace we are completely unlimited  our only limitation is our imagination  butter paper itself does not work with  all pen types or pencils whereas more  folio Trace all you need is the one  simple apple pencil and you have a  hundred different pencils in one worst  of all butter pepper is ridiculously  hard to erase on morpholia Trace simple  just double tap or use a razor tool the  last reason why morpholia Trace is  simply better than a roll of butter  paper is this is never ending you can  have a room full of amazing sketches  whereas you can simply have one iPad to  carry around with you all the time